all right so uh we we made
a there was a comment about having been
doing the releasing drills it's like
kind
of Welling of awareness of the darkness
within came came up and it's it's over a
sense of being overwhelmed
and I
think to me that's real training that's
what training feels like um I think the
idea of
training the development of the skill of
the deconstruction of the ego tripartite
mind that training is has been so um
rebranded by The Wellness
industry so you do a lot of your
training to feel good about yourself to
feel good to feel
pleasure you know to either feel in
better shape or feel better about
oneself to to to stop feeling the
negative kind of
thing um and such that we're we're we're
surprised if we if we happen to be
fortunate enough
to um become proximal to somebody who's
doing real training we get
surprised when this doesn't feel like
that um well that surprise comes from
our delusional belief in the rebranding
of spiritual training as done by the
wellness
industry you can't sell in other
words you what they sell is really the
novice effect okay so for
[Music]
example you know if you are a couch
potato and you start working out you're
going to feel some pleasure because uh
endorphins are going to kick in you're
going to start moving things you're
going to promote circulation you you
know what I mean and so the part of the
novice effect is not
just uh the ability to to make strength
gains for example pretty rapidly but
it's pleasurable at
first it's not
pleasurable as we were mentioning
earlier it's not pleasurable to wake up
at
4:30 to go work out so you can work out
twice a day on your strength training
and then work a 10-hour day and then
come teach you know up to 4 4 hours some
nights like it's not there's no pleasure
in
it it's it's miserable in a way if you
let your mind get into
it but I would never say even if I can
keep my mind out of it I can never say
it's
pleasurable I don't go to
bed you
know at at
9:00 going can't wait to do it
again that's that's not what
happens if I keep my mind if I if I can
release my ego tripartite mind I can
simply do it like
breathing I
don't have pleasure from it it justes
not overwhelm me in in depression or
anything like that but as I get later in
the
week you look at the Sleep the sleep's
not that much I'm pushing the sleep can
can you see that it's not it's not a 8
to n hours it's like a what is that like
a seven to
eight right do you see that and that's a
push
so you you you're pushing that and
somewhere around Thursday Friday
you know I'm like oh God you see my mind
will travel
forward the solution is the same though
I can't be taken by the ego tripartite
mind I have to release the mind as soon
as I release the mind the darkness goes
away if you understand that the ego
tripartite mind as I've said is a system
of course
correspondences they are that it is the
darkness it is the separating force it
is Yen it is
female it is not an anti you it's part
of
you it's not an anti- nature or anti-
Universe it's is part of the universe
the issue that we have in our training
why do we train to be able to
deconstruct the ego Tri protype mind is
because it's prone to
domination and in its
domination we become part of the
darkness and when I say that it's not
that we don't have darkness in us that
we're aren't part of the darkness per se
but we're not taken by
it there's a part of us that is
something other than the
darkness but even though there is a part
of us that is other than the darkness we
really should stop being surprised when
we sense the
darkness we should instead understand it
as just the cosmological order of
things and then we re employ the
mechanism if I can release the ego
tripartite mind the light will come into
me and I can now
remain within the order of
things so comes Thursday
Friday I have to do more of the
releasing skills do you see I have to do
that so maybe like on uh what I've
what's tend to work for me is on
Wednesday I don't I still wake up at
4:30 but I don't come lift weights I
come and do an hour of
releasing you see and then you get like
a Kickstart I finish Thursday
Friday because that that work day and
then the night schedule pushes to sleep
you see on the weekend I don't have the
work days most times I don't have the
night schedule and I can go back to the8
n hour sleep not push
it if you
read the
Masters that the wellness
industry borrows their language
from if you if you go to the source
and not just take their word for it for
what it
is you're going to see that these
Masters described it exactly as I have
to you it is not about a pleasure
seeking we we have the word that we
today use as
Ecstasy but ecstasy in the premod sense
meant exactly what I mean when I say you
reconcile the two minds which means it's
a
Reconciliation of the subject object
economy that is what the word means it's
just over time that word has come to
mean something like pleasure or Joy or
happiness you have a drug named after it
right and it's a party drug do you
see but that's not the original word
so when you look at the ancient Masters
they're not they're telling you in many
ways the the exact opposite as as I have
it's it's not a pleasurable
thing the truly spiritual life the truly
religious life is not a pleasurable
thing you don't do it for pleasure and
so the absence of pleasure
is not indicative of you not doing it in
fact it might be the
opposite it might be the case that your
pleasure is actually a sign that you're
not doing
it this is because of the relationship
between the reification of the self and
it finding everything that reifies
itself
pleasurable and everything that
deconstructs itself it finds
unpleasurable so you have some obvious
cases that we've talked about before
right we've talked about St John and The
Dark Knight many many
times
um this is at the heart of Christian
mysticism or we
recently Ian brought us back to the
desert fathers some some of you you are
reading them again and it's not a
pleasurable
life they out in the
desert seeking what we would call
hardship but living in a way that is not
hardship to them do you see that but you
need the
hardship to see if you could live within
it as if it's not
hardship it's the same in your iido why
do we need a sincere spinal
displacement so that I can act as if I'm
not being spinally
displaced or in the in the rolling we
just
did
right if if there is
no environment in which you would
falter and your ego tripartite mind
would
Thrive then there is no opportunity for
you to free yourself from that
mind okay
so we you you and I Tristan were rolling
I mean did you find it pleasurable was
it pleasurable would you rather roll or
have a shake from Kyle's kitchen do you
know what I mean do you get what I'm
saying but was
it of such a nature that you're like no
this no you hung in there there were
some
laughs you
see but it's not
pleasurable so I would always say as
I've always said to the kids like you're
not really
training until you hate
it we said it too at the beginning like
it's it's a reason to tell you the truth
it's a reason why I just don't like
beginners I mean you guys were not
Buddha Buddhas when you walked in right
you were not
Buddhas you've come a long way with such
things it's almost
like I didn't mind it right but brand
new infants are hard to take care of
right like give I'll take the toddler
years again those were
fun but a real brand new infant you're
like I'm up all night I up all night and
somehow I got to get to work you know
you know what I mean it's hard well a
new person is like that a new person is
like Harden I really don't want to do it
again because you can see how how tough
my own schedule is do you see and very
much like a at this age with this work
schedule you know who knows Mary get
Mary gets pregnant again and it's like
it's a brand new infant I'll be like oh
man okay
I guess I'm waking up at 2:30 now do you
know what I now I better make 6 hours
work or 4 hours work it's going to be
tough do you see do you get what I'm
saying same thing with a new student is
like it's a lot of
work and one of the things that I find
very offputting is how much they love
iido because then I know they're not
training right don't you remember those
days it's like oh I just love it I love
it I want to come all the time I love
this place yeah I don't think you'd be
saying that now do you know what I mean
you have your days when you want to come
and you're like happy to see each other
but come on let's be honest is you're
not like that I remember you all said it
everybody says it I love AO I can't wait
to do it again you know what I
mean it's pleasurable to them because
they're not really
training because all it is doing is
reafy the self and that is not training
the goal of training is to deconstruct
the self and there's no way it's
pleasurable
because the self only Finds Its
reification pleas
pleasurable not its
deconstruction so you got to trust the
ancient Masters you have to trust your
teacher
and you got to kind of
Hope in a weird way that you get there
where there's just no pleasure in this
and that it is actually
terrifying
okay that that dropping of self which is
the phrase the Ancients use I use
deconstruct but it's the same
that dropping of self again if you read
the Masters it is always described as a
death oh it's it's a upic term do you
see but it is quite literal
too from an
idealism is quite
literal but it's quite upic in the sense
it's a kind of poetic because you can
all from this side of
Awakening you know what death is like to
you and it is
terrifying you see and that's how it's
described it's a
death you have to die and then be reborn
But first you have to
die they could have described it like
the like the moderns do right it's a
liberating Joy
you're going to do their ecstatic
dancing they're just trying to get
high it's just a
cope do you get it I love that
word it's the only good thing out of
wokeism it's a
coat it's a it's a it's a salve they put
on the pain of self
and the Wellness in industry has made us
adopt that too and especially
iido right because iido is it's supposed
to be joyful and harmonious and
noninjurious
and uh you know blending and positive
thoughts do you see how that
is is that is that really what it's like
when I throw you and
and your my expectation is you should be
able for me to throw you I mean I can
tone it down right and I can feel you
with
pleasure but I can also go the other
way it's funny because the the the you
know there's many people many many
people that just watch the videos they
will look at
yourami and uh you know they'll do like
like uh great Uki great UK you know way
to follow and all this kind of stuff but
you guys know I'm just chucking you you
don't you're going where I go you're
pretty cool cuz you didn't break your
head but you're still going that way do
you get it and I I I think it's great
that we've moved away from the larger
community and we're in the patreon
community where people have a Keener eye
and I I I finally glad that someone and
a few have been commenting like I would
I would not want to be your UK you see
because you don't get to roll out at
anything you don't you just get thrown
and then you have to land like a cat and
if you really think about
it if you if you really think about
it you can't really figure out how
they're
Landing if you pay
attention cuz you want want to roll you
know what I mean you want you want to do
some sort of rooll they're not really
ever doing a roll the highest seni in
here are not doing a roll they're just
not breaking upon contact if you pay
attention if you if you stop any
throw at the first Contact you you see
that they're basically
going but they're able
to transfer the energy and disperse it
okay if you pay attention even to the
way that we teach the back
breakfall it starts out very circular
right do you know what I mean
like and then we do the Contracting back
break fall do you
see but there's no step from all those
little sequential circular
circular um dispersion of energy step
back step down go there's no step to the
between that and the Contracting Center
back raple drill do right it's just like
what do you do hey just uh hold your
Center and uh find your find your foot
find your foot when you hit the ground
there's nothing to get there do you see
that and if you pay attention we
actually have a division of UK because
some of us can make that jump and some
of us can't because we have no step for
you
right and then if you pay attention when
we do the x
pattern there's no back foot there's no
back foot for you to find there's only
the inside hand of the Contracting
Center back break P you see and we don't
have any steps from the Contracting
Center back bre fall to the x pattern
inner hand you just have to get there
you see and so it makes sense that
someone looking at it would go I'm not
sure how they got there well neither are
they no one's really sure I don't have a
lesson planned for it I just throw you
find the inside hand and you go and
again we have another breaking you cany
who can do that who can't do that
right but there's absolutely nothing
pleasurable in
that I'm not sure anyone would describe
that as harmonious
it's
terrifying and unless you can free
yourself from the
terror you're going to bite it it's
dangerous if you free yourself from the
terror you'll find the inside hand it's
that simple like the the the ego Tri
partite mind wants to go how do I find
it where do I put it you see but the
only answer is free yourself from the
terror free yourself from the terror and
the Hand will be
there but that freedom from Terror first
comes with the facing of Terror there's
no pleasure in that it's the opposite of
it and I wouldn't say I I would would
imagine if you free yourself from the
terror in the middle of the fall and you
go like yeah you're going to bite it
again do you see because it it's not on
the other side it's not the ego triarte
mind goes no Terror bad oh if I could
free myself from Terror then I'll be
happy no because that's still the ego
tripar line so you go I'm going to fight
my arm no no you're not because you were
just filled with that same ego
tripartite mind not going to find the
arm that's why if you look at the faces
of the ukas when they
land they're sto it pay
attention they never are smiling they're
not angry there's nothing do you
see but you could pay attention too to
the
others that I can't throw with the x
pattern or the ones who bite it in the x
pattern look at the face the emotion
shows up on the
face because that's the ego trip part
mind it's stuck between Pleasure and
Pain the pleasure is not
Freedom the wellness industry trying to
sell you something trying to take
advantage of your need for
pleasure it's just another their
drug the way cocaine makes you feel good
or meth makes you feel good mindfulness
training makes you feel good again
though only at the novice level only
then just like the drugs don't the drugs
stop feeling good after a
while do you do your mindfulness
training it feels good at first cuz most
of the time you're living like a crazy
chicken with no head
feels good to
stop but after a while it does nothing
for you it's not real it's not real
training it's just more of the saying I
keep I want to try to feel better I want
to try to feel
pleasure that's what makes you feel pain
that this is going to give you pain
eventually as it
fails now what
so yes and if you read the
Masters the training is terrifying it is
overwhelming if you're doing it right it
is
overwhelming okay so something some
sense of being overwhelmed do you get
it think about
it UK is pushing on you and they're
about to push you over they're about to
overwhelm your position
what's making that
possible you wanted to stay in
place if you just let go and
release they can't overwhelm
you so the same thing you have this
release and a lot of crap that you've
been putting down and
hiding and ignoring and
denying it's going to come up
your ego tripartite mind's going to want
to say no no no don't don't and in that
it Yang yangong clashes with
it under the pressure just like I asked
you to do with UK under the pressure of
UK yield now the conflict's gone now the
overwhelming is gone now the power
struggle is gone because it requires
your participation
so in the same way stuff starts to come
up that's where the release has to
happen be be attentive that your ego
tripartite mind because of its
homeostatic energy is going to say no no
it's going to push on it just like it
does when UK is moving you
no you that's what it
does but the answer is the same release
[Music]
become possess
become
penetrable just like you internalize the
Yang
aspect of UK you it comes through you
comes through the surface of you do you
see and eventually it comes out of you
from the ground out it's passing through
you you're a vessel in the same way
stuff starts to come out stay released
I will
go no sense of
overwhelming just nothing
fine the or the order of things is
working through
me but that's terrifying just like how
many times do I say hey UK can't only
push you unless you're pushing back on
them you you your ego triarte mind goes
he's full of
all you got to do is push harder and
then you're going to be much better
right how many times have I said stop
pushing on ukit and how many times did
you actually go okay yeah check that's
not what happens I just give up right I
just give up you're not going to do it
today that's I stop asking for it right
okay so you should
expect I feel the
release shit's going to come
up I'm going to try to push on it I have
to release keep going okay I have to
keep releasing and therein is my
chance you see that is my chance to
cultivate the skill of releasing so in a
way and I hate to tell you this but I
mean come
on you
up the darkness came and you pushed on
it and that's why you felt over
overwhelmed so you lost your opportunity
to release now you got to do it all
again and it's not so easy at first you
see it's not so easy to release to the
point that the stuff's going to come up
and it's going to trigger you're trying
to push on it
okay it's just like I don't always what
happens when when you fail miserably at
the x pattern if I'm throwing you what
do I do then on the next rep do I give
you an another x pattern no you see I
might even go to another UK right cuz
your chance at it is over it's gone
now now what comes up because that's
important I would
say you should expect to
cry there is a healing aspect to
water and there is a purification aspect
to water and also to
salt and this stuff has to be
purified
okay it's
not I'm not I don't I'm not
sure I mean there might be some some
releasing
but you got to get to a tear
level because of the nature of
water
okay and those tears aren't tears of
depression because the godm can't feel
depression those are purifying
tears and that is how you should
understand them they're
not if you pick pay attention you're not
really crying for
yourself if you are it's not it but if
you pay
attention you're more
feeling
compassion true compassion and those
tears if I were to poetically describe
them they are either tears for
everyone you feel the pain and suffering
of
everyone
or poetically they are uh God crying
through you those are God's tears so you
should not try to shut them off and you
should not try to avoid them they will
stop when you have been purified of
those parts of the darkness that you've
been hiding from yourself